o nosso tema é uma viagem ao mundo
bollywood
vou falar um kids go leu ouviu que ele
então da dança em bollywood a hollywood
eu não gosto da indy ea indústria de
cinema indiana que é falar dele que é a
língua mais falada portanto tem 6 é o
novo livro em si ainda a fusão de mumbai
agora é mumbai mesmo anteriormente seria
com a mãe mas o a palavra hollywood
a fusão destas destino dos números deu
então origem o nome bollywood
o shanxi a este os filmes de bollywood
normalmente são tanto musicais
a música neste tipo de jogos é tão
importantes que no fundo acaba por ser
um sucesso do videoclipe danças acaba se
conhecer um chamativo para depois ver um
filme ou seja um sucesso do show muitas
vezes dependem sim das danças livro e da
música
neste vídeo clips os atores normalmente
não são cantores e exaustão é fazer
apenas a sincronização mundial é e no
fundo existem depois em playback os
cantores profissionais
no entanto as danças em si são então
estas de insensível dentro deste
videoclipe sons das chamadas dessas
bollywood é estas doenças podem desde é
nessas típicas clássicas indianas deus
do mais moderno é ter com alguma mistura
de dança são acidentais
portanto estamos dentro do mando é da
danças bollywood
podemos definir como uma dança livre que
nos leva a viajar pro pela índia e não
só
muitas funções de coisas indianas e não
é através de rituais e fusões musicais
a gente é muito boa tarde como é que nós
levamos essa questão da criatividade a
arte da dança bollywood a criatividade
tem que estar sempre presente desde o
processo de escolha das músicas até à
altura em que estamos no palco atuar
pode acontecer hoje quer ser um passo e
vou ter que inventar tem que puxar pela
criatividade é verdade como estava a
dizer que a questão da escolha da música
mama é uma questão muito importante ela
muito o processo de criatividade e nós
temos que ter atenção muita coisa ao
mesmo tempo ao tipo de público para o
qual nós vamos atuar
temos também terá atenção à own que a
organização não está a pedir em só assim
é que nós nos sentamos escolhemos as
músicas tendo em conta que consideração
estes aspectos e o próprio escolha das
músicas também o processo de
criatividade um processo que é complexo
porque temos canto temos que conseguir
conciliar gostos um do outro e ao mesmo
tempo fazer com que as músicas e e
seqüência das músicas passa sentidos não
só para o evento mas como para o público
porque na maioria dos casos quando
atuamos é pra públicos que não sou
falante cindy então no fundo têm que
perceber o que é que nós estamos a fazer
é importante nós com a nossa seqüência
conseguimos demonstrar de forma clara o
que nós estamos a apresentar a
criatividade também pode ser colocada
exibida através da nossa opção por prova
a nossa expressão corporal vai definir
muito a nossa atuação é a junção dos
nossos movimentos os nossos gestos por
assim dizer que aquilo que nós fazemos
com o nosso rosto
o público vai sentir cativado assente
interessado com esta mistura seja da
roupa também a roupa também uma questão
muito importantes do guarda-roupa
indumentária os adoro a áustria o bólido
nós vamos nessa
como é remar fria muito bem hum
a nossa roupa é também vai ter vai de
encontro ao futebol e nós vamos dançar
porque existem vários tipos de bollywood
e cada estilo a ter um tipo de roupa
diferente e é engraçado porque a roupa
também pode definir não só em termos
geográficos mas também pode definir pode
contestou os anos em termos históricos
em termos temporais onde esta doença
estava passado pode ser uma dança sobre
os tempos sobre as regras do dos antigos
marajás do shas ea roupa vai nos ajudar
a transmitir essa idéia ao público
portanto é muito é toda uma fusão de
processos criatividade é na apresentação
de dança bild
é um trabalho de fim de ano quando foi
lançado o desafio começamos logo
imaginar começamos por isso em palco é
um caminho árduo mas como vivemos um
sonho é sempre uma forma de motivá ao eu
transmitir essa alegria e muita força me
ajudando sempre tempo é que vamos sempre
procurei outras situações profissionais
vamos lá gostam desta situação e vamos
abraçar este desafio - acaba por
guilherme bastante até mesmo no seio da
comunidade comunidade de vez em quando
assim em casa porque o conceito aliás é
mesmo mais anos anne tudo isto portanto
acabam escura dar um orgulho neste tipo
de eventos
a minha sugestão é portanto nós passamos
tanto tempo na nossa vida a fazer aquilo
que temos de fazer
devemos também ter algum espaço na nossa
vida a fazer com que manas e assim criar
a nossa incredulidade e com e assim
também vocês fazem ninhos somente e isso
é o que nós vamos mostrar os então eu
sugeri então que neste caso agora
fizemos aquilo que mais gostamos não é
fizemos uma demonstração dessa bollywood
e após a demonstração dessa bola do que
teríamos que se juntassem a nós para um
mini workshop de dança
já agora nossa apresentação vai ter em
conta dois tios do óleo diferente e não
deixam de ser de bollywood mesmo um é
mais romântico
já o nível daquilo que nós estamos
habituados a ver nos filmes indianos
fumaça o amor
e o segundo é a segunda parte da dança
vai ser sobre ele acha o estilo musical
já em grande estilo musical da zona do
pam diabo já é muito mais animado e mais
divertida e vamos convidar pois o
público a juntar-se a nós prevemos costa
então
[Música]
i
não
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sem marra
limpar o tema ranking
queremos
o tempo de júri
dona de have to
é noite
[Música]
não medi abril
minha mãe pega em adulta ficar toalha aí
nem corre o risco de o time carioca tem
mais cuidado na escolha de tite
[Música]
ontem assunto porque te levo comigo no
pará chega lá como cá aquela palha de
cana como nunca na chamada hora do
planeta em caracas
[Música]
[Aplausos]